you know I'm supposed to be on vacation
why are they releasing all these
trailers at the same damn
time Star Wars the Force awakens first
trailer is now out thoughts on this I
really don't have anything to complain
about in this trailer as opposed to
Jurassic world that said it doesn't
necessarily get me excited that's not
really the fault of the trailer though
at this point I'm so Jaded by what
happened with the prequels that my level
of inherent excitement is not very high
I still hope the movies are good I think
there's a fair chance they will be I
will go and see them but it's probably
going to be the movie itself that's
going to have to win me over the
marketing I'm sorry I'm not going to get
won over by the marketing cuz the
marketing for the prequels was good but
the movies weren't that said there's a
couple of things that I really like
about what they do here the first is how
much new stuff they show us in terms of
characters we see things that we see
happen it's almost all new I mean
there's a couple of nasda old stuff we
see some Stormtroopers we see some
vehicles that we've seen before I love
that they saved the Millennium Falcon
for the end cuz that that was about the
one part that I sort of like oh just
that extended shot of the Falcon that
that was just really well put together
and really well timed in terms of where
it fell in the placement in the trailer
and it does make me curious about what's
going on seeing Stormtroopers kind of
made me go well thought we got rid of
the Empire and it does sort of get my
brain rolling well okay they took out
the emperor but the infrastructure is
all still there and that infrastructure
was kind of dependent on things being
enforced by Stormtroopers they don't
just suddenly poof vanish cuz the
emperor was gotten rid of so I find that
interesting just off the bat the fact
that they're even there I had another
friend who kind of pointed out to me and
and once he mentioned it I did
appreciate this how much negative space
there is in these shots this is not what
Lucas ended up doing in the prequels
which is to cram as much as possible
into the frame there's a lot of very
clear Focus here's the shot here's where
your focus is and now here's a nice open
landscape behind the thing that you're
focusing on that's just nice structure
and that's much more visually appealing
and it reads much more quickly and is
really good for the trailer now I don't
expect the whole movie to make that much
use of negative space but for what they
chose for the teaser very well chosen
because it allows you to immediately
focus on what it is that you should be
focusing on in any given shot or a small
little piece they used you know I said I
don't have any complaints I I suppose I
have one the thing with the the
lightsaber that we see and it's red so
it's obviously a Sith and then the
little come out and looks like like a
broadsword hilt is what it ends up
looking at I I kind of snickered when
they did that cuz they're they're
obviously trying very hard to go for the
raw impact of when Darth Maul had the
two bladed it's not bad I'm sorry that
that moment especially in the early
trailers to Phantom Menace you can't top
that moment for oh wow and they tried
and I they probably would have been
better off not trying to match that and
just from a practical standpoint seeing
those little two things on the side I'm
just thinking of the way we've seen
lightsabers used up to this point and
the way they're used and the way they're
handled they're not handled like big
heavy broadswords where you need a hilt
for blocking purposes they're handled
with a bit more finesse it's a it's
closer defensing in terms of really
quick motions and everything and I would
imagine things sticking out the size
like that that would be more of a
detriment to the person wielding the
thing than anyone that he's going up
against I mean you know to be fair we
haven't seen the thing in action that
may swing me over but just on concept
I'm looking at going I don't know about
that I mean the double bladed one was
probably a very big Hazard to be
wielding as well but you see that and
you go whoa if you know what you're
doing you can really tear something up
with that you see the little things on
the side you go well you know what
you're doing you could I don't know what
could you use that for it shows good
stuff it gave us images and especially
you know the music at the very end that
we are familiar with and all the
nostalgic folks can go oh yeah but it
was plenty of new imagery so that we're
getting hooked hopefully into what is
new about it instead of just aping the
now 70-year-old main cast that's coming
back which I'm very happy they're coming
back but I'm glad they weren't put front
and center right off the bat hang back a
little save them for a little bit I like
that approach but like like I said my
actual enthusiasm for the movie itself
has not gone up at all with this but as
we saw what happened with the Jurassic
World trailer it didn't dampen my
enthusiasm which is what that trailer
managed to do so you know the fact that
they were able to release something and
it didn't make go yeah here's everything
that's going to be wrong with that I
suppose that we'll count that as a win
so the first trailer for the new Star
Wars movie did you see it I'm assuming
you probably have by now so what did you
think about it whatever it is you
thought drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it until
next time this council is
adjourned